with 18 000 police officers guarding the
summit these protesters rode their luck
and tried to grab the attention of the
leaders urging the g7 to do everything
possible to stop the war in ukraine
they're talking about the war the
destruction of the world the climate
catastrophe and we want to show our
protest
inside the castle ukrainian president
zelinski invited to attend fire video
link was asking for more weapons telling
the g7 leaders he wanted the war to be
over before winter for their part the
united states announced it would send
new advanced air defense systems to
ukraine
while g7 leaders discussed increasing
military firepower nato chief yan
stoltenberg in brussels announce a large
expansion of battle-ready troops we will
strengthen our forward defenses
we will enhance our battlegroups in the
eastern part of the alliance
up to brigade levels
we will transform the nato response
force
and increase the number of our high
readiness forces to well over
300 000
such massive numbers making this the
biggest overhaul of nato's deterrent
since the cold war
it is clear that this war has a very
deep impact on international relations
as i said before i see russia's attack
on ukraine as a turning point all
international rules of corporation have
been broken especially that borders
can't be changed by force we as g7 agree
that these will be long lasting effects
and will stay with us a very long time
and influence international relations
for a very long time
it's been a delicate balancing act here
at the castle thousand meters high in
the bavarian alps how to increase
pressure on russia and continue to
support ukraine while making sure that
sanctions won't backfire on g7 economies
developing countries are also paying a
very high price
indonesian president joko widodo invited
as one of the guests to the summit urged
the g7 to find a solution to the food
crisis hitting developing nations as a
result of the war together with u.n
secretary general antonio guterres
leaders discussed ways to lift the
blockade of ukrainian food stocks with
widespread humanitarian disasters
looming and the war in ukraine ongoing
g7 leaders will leave the bavarian alps
with multiple crises unresolved next on
their agenda the nato summit in madrid
later this week step fast on al jazeera
and garmish partnership